alright I know the shirts gonna end up
slightly funky with the green screen
effect I don't care it's too perfect
this may seem like an odd time to come
out with the game of thrones list but
honestly I think is the perfect time to
tackle the specific line that I want to
talk about which is that as the show has
gotten bigger and more expansive there
are certain plot points that seem to
have dropped off and been forgotten
about some have always been relatively
minor some seemed pretty important but
the show seems to have gun app whatever
we don't need that anymore now it is
possible that summer maybe even all of
the things I'm about to talk about will
in fact be picked up again and become a
through line by the time the show wraps
up I don't know but so far there's no
indication on any of this I know sevens
a bit of an awkward number but I
couldn't come up with ten so here we go
number 79 Maria this would be Arya's
direwolf obviously at won't put all the
start kids had direwolves some of those
holes are still alive some of them are
dead night Mary is a bit of an odd one
though because she was specifically
released in sep free to avoid getting
killed and you'd think that the dog
would like hang around and rican
reconnect with are you at some point and
I suppose as possible that could still
happen but she just kind of banished
like to the point of okay why was she
saved I mean I yeah I get that you know
she was saved lady was killed in this
place sort of for more of a rift between
Sansa and her father's I guess I get
that but it just it seemed weird that
the wolf got free and that's never fact
in factored into anything hasn't even
been mentioned that the wolf's like out
there terrorizing local countryside's
just gnaw wolves free and gone by number
six rebelling cities it got mentioned a
number of times since Joffrey took the
throne you know during the whole war for
the Iron Throne and even been after he
was dead and Tommen took over that
various cities across the nation have
been rebelling and it's not something
we've ever really seen I mean I'm not
talking about the North coming going
against King's Landing they see there
was mention of yo just individual cities
rebelling and sort of fighting against
Kingsguard or what not and never seen
any of that I mean I understand that
sort of thing is the sort of thing that
the show tends to not show too much of
because battles are expensive especially
if they involve a lot of people but it's
weird that it was ever even brought up
because it doesn't seem to factor it
into anything either it's not like those
rebelling cities like their resources
ever got taken on it used by somebody
else who was important and somebody we
knew it just it's odd that it was ever
dropped in as something that was going
on number five Rick on and OSHA this is
why I'm not sure I actually want this
picked up cuz osha I kind of liked but
Rick and never added anything but at the
same time they're still alive and you
know Rick on as a surviving Stark is
theoretically important for that reason
if nothing else but but no real
indication that we're ever gonna find
out what ever happened with them I mean
obviously bran will come back and then
we'll find out more what's going on
there Rickon OSHA not a lot of
indicators there i mean i'm not sure
what there is to actually do with them
but since there isn't really anything to
do why did they need to live I mean I'm
not saying that like I'm blood thurs you
like well if you're not going to use
them just kill them but given how
readily the show does kill people when
it goes out of its way to make sure
certain characters live and then doesn't
use them again in any way it's it's a
little weird number four Walder Frey now
I'm fairly confident that he's gonna be
dealt with again at some point but since
the show opted not to include Lady
Stoneheart I'm not sure who there is to
even like get Walder Frey involved in
things again I mean nobody really has
any investment in dealing with him I
mean I suppose as possible I mean the
show you know very much as you know
sometimes the world's unfair and people
get away with stuff maybe we'll just
never deal with it he'll just kill the
Starks and that's it but that's that's
kind of a kick in the balls and and even
if we don't deal with him in a sort of
we need revenge for the Starks waving
he's always kind of held an important
chunk of land you think he'd come up
again at some point I don't know number
three
Gendry Robert's bastard son whose blood
was so vital to the woman and Red's
magic and then was sent off in a boat
I'm sure he's fine I don't know again
that's another case where it's weird
that the show left him alive and then
did nothing with him again much for the
same reason that I brought up a
nightmare you and Rick on an OSHA I mean
the show is just so casual about killing
characters I was gonna say killing kids
would serve no function but even killing
characters who have a vital function so
you'd think that characters left alive
would be important but there's been no
indicator of him coming back or do
anything no word no anything and it's
been a while now I'm not sure we're
getting him back number two brothers
without banners now this one this is a
weird one to me because when they were
first introduced I like them a heck of a
lot more than I liked lady Melisandre in
terms of servants of the Lord of life
who were wielding magic I found them way
more interesting so the fact that
they've never come back as really kind
of bothered me especially since there's
all this emphasis put on you know they
can raise view from the den there's this
one guy who seems to be losing bits of
himself every time he comes back and
none of that returns I mean I I suppose
it could just be setting up that people
can have this ability and then you know
establishing the lady miss Sandra is
connected to them you know there's all
the theories that she's gonna raise John
or whatever else so who knows so maybe
they were only there to establish things
that were possible but they're just a
cool group and it seems like a waste not
to actually have them come back and
what's more they felt like they had an
agenda like they had things they wanted
to do and those things if they were
successful we're going to impact the
characters we're still following so did
they just go on vacation but finally the
one that has been driving me crazy
blackfish not a start per se but a
relative of those characters and who was
there at the red wedding but left to go
take a piss was not killed at the red
wedding and actually at the start of the
following season they even made a point
of saying he got away we don't know what
to him so not only did you not show him
die you made an extra point of going
this guy's still alive ooh I'm sure it
matters maybe now we're bored with him
forget it I mean it's just again this
one much more so than all the other ones
that I point out where characters live
but then don't seem to have a function
like the show reminded us that he is
still alive and yet has done nothing
with him for years now again maybe he'll
come back maybe all these things will
come back and all wrap up especially
maybe in this last season everything
comes to a head all the loose strands
come back together and I look at the
whole scope of the thing and go wow it
was worth the weight of three four
seasons however long it was for that
thing to come back and into play but I
think there's actually a fairly good
chance that as the show went along the
people behind it realized no we actually
don't really need to pay that off we
want to focus on other things and are
just going to let these things drop any
thoughts on any of these dangling plot
threads that the show is currently left
us do you think any of these will get
resolved do you want any of them to be
resolved do you not care about any of
these whatever your thoughts on the
whole thing drop something down in the
comments and let's talk about it until
next time this council is a German